peine à une dépolitisation absolument
pour moi de l'économie nationale par
rapport à ce qu'on aille les gays à
l'union européenne en termes je parle
des go pay souvent les grands entretiens
d'orientation passant de politique
économique là dessus on n'a pas la main
la réforme des retraites par exemple
chômage mais la réforme des retraites
c'est aussi voilà
et il a dessus à partir du moment où
c'est toujours côté de la souveraineté
ou pas est-ce qu'on reprend sa
souveraineté ou pas est-ce qu'on accepte
la concurrence libre et non faussée
est-ce qu'on veut se mettre en
concurrence avec tous les autres pays de
la zone euro c'est compliqué quand vous
allez en pologne
vous voyez que entre l'aéroport de
cracovie de l'outil par contre et la
ville aujourd'hui vous avez une
conurbation de sièges sociaux
d'entreprises d'europe de chez nous donc
il ya finalement des gens qui ont
bénéficié de truites ont bénéficié et
finalement ça en partie cassé l'emploi
on va dire non qualifiés en france dans
le chômage de masse moi je veux bien
mais à un moment donné va falloir se
poser la question concrètement c'est
l'union européenne et de son impact sur
nos politiques
on a plus aujourd'hui pour moi ça c'est
un avis personnel on n'a plus la main ce
levier d'un politiquement le faire de
façon l'union européenne interdit
l'inflation d'ailleurs c'est donc tout
ça à mon avis c'est lié c'est une
corrélation voilà il on peut en discuter